quelle mère infos médias jean michel
maire c'est vrai vous deviez faire le
bachelor et bien je vais vous dire
pourquoi le bachelor c'est un format
warner donc est ce un format américain
et les américains j'avais vraiment le
temps que moi j'ai fait pareil que
j'étais little big star n'a pas et sur
ses 8 qui avec des enfants donc ils sont
obligés de demander l'accord des
américains quand ils choisissent un
animal et donc ils ont envoyé des vidéos
de vous aux etats unis les stocks est
off best of 7 oui c'est à dire bon bah y
avait eu donc les avait un cadeau je
suis dit stop stop
what i stars et donc et donc les
américains ont refusé a indiqué que vous
soyez le bachelor ce qu'ils ont dit vous
corresponde y est pas elle n'allait pas
tous les critères le comprendre pour
repenser que les américains vont
accepter moi oui oui monsieur plus près
de donald oui c'est rien il regarde pas
ça vous inquiétez pas en tout cas très
bonne question de ben ali qui a pu
déboucher sur une réponse mon entrain de
voir on est en train de faire un autre
truc peut-être pour vous on en train de
voir sur un autre